[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi à 25 juin
tout de suite les titres de se situer du
journal est la grève va se poursuivre
cet été à la sncf
alors que le mouvement en perd les deux
trois mois prend fin ce jeudi est la cgt
cheminots a confirmé qu'elle serait
encore mobilisés en juillet et en août
pourtant la réforme ferroviaire motif du
début de la contestation a été adoptée
au parlement entretien à suivre dans
cette édition un patrimoine autant de la
seconde guerre mondiale le château de
versailles a vécu pendant quatre ans
sous l'occupation allemande dans son
ouvrage le soleil le soleil éclipsé et
clervaux note revient sur cette période
de péril longue de mille cinq cents
jours pour le domaine elle est notre
invité et puis retour sur le championnat
de france de course de voitures
radiocommandées la quatrième manche se
tenait ce week end à maurepas plus de
100 pilotes ont pu se défier sur le
circuit yvelinois avant de développer
ces titres la semaine de quatre jours
largement plébiscité dans les yvelines
d'après des projections de la direction
académique de versailles 90% des
communes possédant au moins une école
seront revenus à cette formule à la
rentrée
aujourd'hui déjà 202 villes ont fait ce
choix rendue possible depuis
l'assouplissement de la loi sur les
rythmes scolaires est d'autres communes
en minorité comme trappe saint cyr
l'école et viroflay ont décidé elle de
rester une semaine de quatre jours et
demi pour leurs écoliers
je vous en reparler dans les titres et
la cgt cheminots appellent à continuer
la grève à la sncf en juillet et en août
c'est pour protester contre la réforme
ferroviaire adopté au parlement le 14
juin pour cette nouvelle mobilisation
cet été la cgt fait pour le moment en
cavalier seul mais pourrait être
rejointe par d'autres fédérations
entretien
[Musique]
axel personne est avec moi sur ce
plateau bonsoir ça vous êtes le
secrétaire général de la cgt cheminots
de trappes le syndicat qui appelle à
poursuivre la grève à la sncf en juillet
et en août rappelons que vous êtes
mobilisés depuis début avril dans un
mouvement d'hyper les derniers épisodes
de cette grève en pointillés ce mercredi
et jeudi
alors un premier bilan déjà de cette
séquence de trois mois de grève la
motivation dans vos rangs at elle
augmenté c'est allé souffler au cours de
ces trois mois
la détermination est toujours très
présente et en tout cas ce qui est sa
une certitude c'est que l'opposition aux
attaques que le gouvernement vous nous
imposez elle est toujours là après
évidemment ça va de soi qu après trois
mois de mobilisation parce que ça va
commencer en réalité le 22 mars
évidemment les grévistes sont fatigués
c'est normal parce que ça demande un
investissement financier et militant
extrêmement importants qui pèsent sur
les familles qui pèsent sur la santé
physique et mentale presque parfois en
tout cas la détermination à poursuivre
la bagarre est encore présente dans des
noyaux très très important est en tout
cas même chez les collègues qui ont
ponctué le mans repris le travail
l'opposition à la réforme elle est
toujours présente je suis convaincu
aussi que partant de ce constat on va
pouvoir continuer la bataille d'autant
plus qu' une décision plutôt favorable
nous a été rendu aujourd'hui en terme de
justice puisque la direction a été
condamné pour ses pratiques visant
retenir des retenues de salaire plus
importante que ce que nous avons
effectivement cessé comme travail et
rappelons que cette contestation est née
injustement opposition au projet de loi
de réforme ferroviaire qui a été
finalement adopté c'était à la mi juin
alors si on s'interroge sur la forme de
la grève le faire de façon en séquences
de façon père les a peut-être pu
interroger en tout cas au niveau d'un
sondage du jdd 42% des français a trouvé
cette grève justifiée en avril 37%
engeance a donc baissé ça pose peut-être
là la question de l'efficacité de labre
de la grève était ce le bon choix
finalement de la sphère en pointillés de
la faire par séquences sur trois mois en
tout cas c'est le choix qu'ils étaient
majoritairement retenue dans les
assemblées générales
parce que c'est aussi ce mode de
l'acquis pour l'instant en tout cas nous
a permis de tenir aussi longtemps après
la plus grosse difficulté de ce
mouvement ce n'est pas tant la
détermination des cheminots qui est
largement démontré leur implication dans
la grève ce qui pèse un peu plus sur les
capacités les potentiels du mouvement
c'est évidemment pour l'instant le fait
que les cheminots sont relativement je
dis bien relativement isolé puisque pour
l'instant il n'y a pas encore d'autres
secteurs qui entraient en grève
reconductible comme le font les
cheminots la situation changera un tout
petit peu maintenant puisque dans
l'énergie il ya un mouvement de grève
reconductible pour le coup avec
occupation des sites qui a débuté dans
la mesure où ce sont exactement les
mêmes attaques proposent aux cheminots
qui vont être imposés à nos camarades de
l'énergie et donc là il ya un mouvement
qui a réellement démarré dans l'énergie
donc de ce point de vue là on a un peu
moins isolé ça arrive un peu tard mais
on va se poser la question donc comment
on fait pour articuler tous ces éléments
avoir la meilleure stratégie pour à la
fois pouvoir poursuivre pendant l'été en
tenant compte donc du fait qu'on est en
vacances qui a moins de militants sur le
terrain mais en faisant en sorte que la
continuer la médiation puisse continuer
cet été et qu'elle puisse si nécessaire
continue même au delà de l'été parce que
en tout cas ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui à
tous les cheminots la loi allait
peut-être voter en tout cas une
revendication elle demeure aujourd'hui
j'avais les vous relancez sûr c'est la
loi a été votée définitivement le 14
juin
pourquoi finalement continuer le
mouvement vous espérez encore peser sur
des décrets des ordonnances qui vont
être inscrits sur sur cette loi
l'histoire sociale quand même de ce pays
elle démontre aussi qu'il ya eu
énormément de loi qui ont déjà été votés
et qu'ils n'en soient jamais été
promulgué soit jamais été appliquée du
fait d'une mobilisation sociale alors
qu'elle avait déjà été voté je pense pas
forcément il y aura évidemment l'exemple
très connu que moi j'ai connu du c'est
peu mais ya pas que le cpe il ya aussi
l'écotaxe si on remonte du temps de
balladur il y avait le contrat
d'insertion pour les jeunes si on
remontait dans 53 à l'époque s'appelait
pas des ordonnances après lé décret loi
sur les retraites
ça aussi ça avait été passé et ça va
être retirée du fait d'une mobilisation
donc pour nous le vote de ce qui se
passe au palais bourbon au palais du
luxembourg c'est pas ça qui conditionne
la relation aujourd'hui quelles sont
elles les revendications restent les
mêmes c'est à dire qu'on est opposés
évidemment au projet de destruction du
système ferroviaire de sa privatisation
en région par région puisque rappelons
que cette loi prévoit donc la fin du
statut de cheminot à terme y aura plus
de statut de cheminot également à
l'ouverture à la concurrence pardon de
la sncf
un changement de statut juridique aussi
c'est entre autres à retenir
vous êtes encore opposés sur ces points
la question n'est encore pas assez pour
la d'ailleurs je conteste même un peu
la description du projet de loi parce
qu'il parle d'ouverture à la concurrence
mais ce n'est pas vrai en fait c'était
pas vrai qu'il va y avoir plein de
nouvelles entreprises qui vont proposer
un service alternatif à la sncf qui vont
construire des nouvelles gares des
nouvelles voies acheter de nouveaux
matériels et embaucher de nouveaux
personnels pour proposer un service
alternatif à celui existant
là le projet qu'on veut nous imposer
c'est de récupérer pour les opérateurs
privés ou les filiales du groupe sncf
le matériel déjà existants le personnel
de la forme existants qu'on transfère de
force dans ses structures et aux
conditions qu'eux ils ont décidé
unilatéralement et surtout ses filiales
et ses opérateurs là que ce qu'ils
existent et de récupérer ce marché et le
monopole d'exploitation de ces dix
marchés pour pas qu'ils concurrencent
tant que pour nous évidemment on est
opposé on reste opposé à ce projet de
loi et partant de là le principe de la
grève ça reste assez simple au final
c'est que l'on se met en grève jusqu'à
quand va jusqu'à ce que les grévistes
décident d'arrêter mais le but c'est
bien évidemment de faire grève jusqu'à
satisfaction des revendications donc
partant de là oui on continue le combat
une grève en juillet en août donc ça va
se poursuivre le syndicat sud rail
semble continuer également le mouvement
l'unsa a dit à d'ores et déjà annoncé
qu'elle se retirait de ce moment la cfdt
d'après les propos de son secrétaire
général ne suivrait pas non plus il dit
que continue la grève ça ce serait
donner une mauvaise image du
syndicalisme
le fait qu'ils aient pu forcément
d'union sur ces grèves qui vont
continuer en juillet-août est-ce que
c'est aussi une faiblesse
disons le choix des syndicats et je
parle pour tous les syndicats évidemment
les regarde ça peut peser dans un
conflit mais au final comme toujours
c'est les cheminots qui décident s'il
continue ou pas et aujourd'hui en tout
cas même si évidemment après trois mois
c'est difficile
il reste quand même des noyaux de
grévistes extrêmement importants
notamment à la conduite des trains dont
je fais partie ou encore des dépôts qui
sont en grève de façon majoritaire et là
je parle des chiffres de la direction
donc c'est eux qui vont décider si on
continue ou pas la grève et les
remontées qu'on a majoritairement dans
les assemblées générales part d'un
constat simple oui c'est difficile
oui la grève pèse sur nos finances mais
vu les attaques on n'a pas le choix il
faut qu'on continue cet été après il
peut avoir des débats sur quelles sont
les dates les plus pertinentes pour se
mettre en grève cet été ça c'est des
débats qu'on a eu dans les assemblées
générales un peu partout mais c'est une
décision qui va être prise là d'ici la
fin de la semaine ne serait pas
forcément sur les dates de départs en
vacances a été en tout cas annoncés par
la cgt cheminots merci axel personnes
d'avoir été impossible sans papiers
parce que que les deux ans qu'ils ont
évidemment on s'interdit pas de le faire
on va le faire d'ailleurs que vous dire
qu'on va le faire
merci avec cette personne d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes le
secrétaire général de la cgt cheminots
de trappes et depuis l'enregistrement de
cet entretien la cgt a appelé à la grève
à la sncf pour les journées des 6 et 7
juillet à date des premiers départs en
vacances d'été dans la vallée de
chevreuse désormais vous pouvez payer
autrement qu en euros la racine a été
lancée ce week-end cette monnaie locale
est utilisable dans une vingtaine de
commerces pour le moment une racine vaut
environ 1 euro 15 mille billets sont en
circulation
l'objectif c'est de stimuler l'économie
locale et de favoriser le lien social
pour utiliser cette monnaie il faut être
adhérent de l'association l'aracine dans
l'actualité locale également la première
phase des travaux du mile dessolés lancé
à vue en cours depuis la mi juin plus de
200 arbres sont en cours d'abattage
une opération qui devrait durer six
semaines avant de commencer la
rénovation globale entre les quartiers
et des saules et du parc les détails de
nicolas landry le mail percée saule
pleureur vieux est atteint par un
champignon de ces arbres sont abattus
une décision prise suite à une
consultation d'experts en botanique donc
là s'était bel emplacement d'un arbre
qui n'est plus à ce qui est déjà un
tiers des arbres de talent et qui ont dû
être abattus ou qui sont tombés à cause
de la maladie leur affaiblissement qui
n'ont aujourd'hui plus assez d'eau pour
se nourrir de l'âge aussi parce que
c'était des arbres qui ont plus de 40
ans la rénovation du mail des sols un
engagement de la majorité municipale
coût de l'investissement plus de 2
millions d'euros une opération en
plusieurs phases des travaux sur le
quartier des sols et le quartier du parc
avant de restructurer la place centrale
la différence avec le projecteur c'est
que la circulation piétonne ce don qui
reste bien sûr un my piétons et aux
circulations douces vélo se fera sur un
axe central
il y aura dans le nouveau projet je
crois que c'est 1000 m² de surface
végétale en plus par rapport à
l'existant et bien moi je suis contente
que les travaux se met en route parce
que
chaque tempête on avait toujours peur
cranach tombe sur quelqu'un depuis déjà
plusieurs années donc c'est une bonne
chose c'est très bien sauf que
ça m'a fait un peu bizarre quand ils ont
coupé tous les arbres
parce que là
citation c'était quand même sympa après
c'est vrai que ça cache et la luminosité
mais j'espère qu'il y aura quand même un
peu d'armes
les habitants des deux quartiers ont été
consultés par la municipalité
mais certaines réserves persistent sur
le projet notamment olivier paréja
conseiller municipal qui souhaitent le
marquage de pistes cyclables sur la zone
partagée le château de versailles à
l'ombre de l'occupation allemande
pendant quatre ans au cours de la
seconde guerre mondiale les troupes
nazies ont investi les lieux bonsoir à
clairvaux note
vous êtes diplômé de l'école du louvre
docteur en histoire de l'art
collaboratrice scientifique du musée du
château de versailles alors vous publiez
haché vendémiaire ce livre le soleil
éclipsé le château de versailles sous
l'occupation siv est finalement une
période méconnue de l'histoire du
domaine et qui a duré mille cinq cents
jours pourquoi écrire sur le sujet alors
il ya plusieurs raisons à cela la
première c'est le faut bien avouer que
les 19e et 20e siècles sont les travaux
enfin concernant cette période font
figure de parents pauvres par rapport
aux travaux consacrés à l'ancien régime
dont versailles le château est vraiment
une carte à jouer sur sur cette période
la deuxième c'est que j'ai eu
l'opportunité de
de travailler sur des archives en lien
avec cette période quand j'étais chargé
d'études et de recherches à l'institut
national d'histoire de l'art à paris et
finalement de fil en aiguille je me suis
vraiment piqué de curiosité pour ce
sujet et j'ai commencé à travailler au
château à partir de la fin des années
2000 2008 et ça a été l'occasion pour
moi de poursuivre au civil enquête
alors si on regarde ce livre le contenu
de ce livre 300 pages d'écriture des
photos des cartes beaucoup aussi
d'annotations et une bibliographie
fourni compilé toutes ces informations
c'est un travail titanesque
j'avoue c'est un travail titanesque
c'est surtout un travail de fourmi
puisqu'il faut a finalement essayé de
rechercher une vérité est recherché
voilà des témoignages ça suppose aussi
de croiser un certain nombre de sources
alors bon le principal mon principal
outil ça a été les archives les archives
alors que tout d'abord j'ai commencé à
rechercher dans les archives bas de
l'île de france
donc j'ai évoqué le la bibliothèque de
l'institut national d'histoire de l'art
à paris il ya également les archives
nationales
les archives départementales des
yvelines à montigny-le-bretonneux les
archives bien évidemment du château
puisque on conserve quand même un
certain nombre de documents des photos
des photographies également et par la
suite je vois là j'ai essayé d'ouvrir le
spectre en allant en province puisqu'il
y avait des dépôts des collections de
verse du château de versailles fin du
musée en province et donc je suis allé
du côté de danger dans les archives de
du maine et loire où j'ai trouvé
certains certains témoignages et enfin
voilà pour ne pas se limiter à vraiment
un discours et une vision uniquement
franco française je suis allé en
allemagne dans les archives fédérales de
berlin et de fribourg lors de multiples
sources et nous reste trois minutes
juste si on rentre dans le contenu de
l'ouvragé l'occupation du domaine a
débuté le 14 juin 1940 on est à quelques
jours de la signature de l'armistice
entre la france et l'allemagne qui se
déroule en forêt de compiègne et qui
établit les conditions de l'occupation
le château de versailles c'est un réel
objectif militaire pour pour les
allemands ou finalement c'était plus un
symbole de l'occuper alors c'est plus un
symbole
il faut bien comprendre que le château
constitue une sorte de d'épicentre dans
le cadet des conflits franco-allemands
et le sport un de chaque côté du rhin on
vient entériner la victoire dans la
galerie des glaces
alors c'est le cas en 1871 avec le sac
de guillaume premier
dans la galerie est également bien
évidemment le 1919 avec le traité de
versailles qui constitue vraiment le
ensuite le point focal et la n2 vécue
par comme une véritable humiliation pour
les allemands le traité oui comme une
véritable humiliation il ya une si vous
voulez il ya une forme d'ambiguïté dans
les discours notamment dit leur indique
l'arrêt de ses ministres il appelle à la
destruction et à la fin de versailles et
sélection long si on le lit sous l'angle
du monument il ya de quoi frémir
fort heureusement il est il est toujours
question du traité des clauses du traité
et non pas du monument tant qu en tant
que tel
alors vous dites oh dans l'ouvragé au
moment du début de la seconde guerre
mondiale le château de versailles une
drôle d'alluré pas beaucoup de visiteurs
et aussi vidé de ses principales
sculpture parce que à partir des années
1930 on va commencer à vider le château
il ya un plan un plan de protection qui
a été élaboré c'est pas le cas
uniquement pour versailles c'est le cas
pour d'autres musées nationaux ou
d'autres monuments historiques mais donc
dès le début des années 30 on sent que
le conflit va se s'annonce et ont fait 1
on prépare vraiment le ce conflit en
mettant voilà on établit des l'histoire
de protection avec les oeuvres à évacuer
en première urgence et une partie des
collections seront évacués dès l'automne
1939 dans des châteaux de province à
chambord chambord château le château de
chambord de grissac et de sourds ch vous
reste 30 secondes alors pour découvrir
la suite du contenu j invite les
téléspectateurs à acheter ce livre
juste cite une enquête qui est ouverte
c'est dire que vous prévoyez de sortir
d'autres éditions de ce livre enrichi
alors si voilà je recueille d'autres
témoignages voilà et de bien vite tous
ceux qui auraient voit d'autres éléments
à me fournir de m'écrire voilà au
château de versailles la fiche actuelle
mois là pour m'apporter tout témoignage
parce que l'anc est l' enquête mais il
ne sera jamais permis n'ont jamais
terminé merci claire bonnot d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
l'auteur de ce livre le soleil éclipsé
le château de versailles sous
l'occupation et c'est un livre que vous
pouvez retrouver aux éditions
vendémiaire une course de voitures à
présent radio commandé le mot repas
modélisme club organisait ce week-end la
quatrième manche du championnat de
france de la discipline près de 100
pilotes sont venus de toute la france
pour s'affronter sur le circuit
yvelinois nicolas landry était dans les
paddocks regarder les moteurs tournent
les voitures chauffer les pneus lors du
tour de formation
c'est la demi-finale de cette 4e manche
du championnat de france de voitures
radiocommandées des bolides à l'échelle
1 8e sur la piste de morphée c'est un
circuit qui est assez rapide
les difficultés c'est les passages de
bosses et le circuit et au lieu d'être
en largeur ce qu'on trouve
habituellement il est plutôt en
profondeur donc en fait on est obligé
mais tu es piotte sur une zone surélevée
à trois mètres de hauteur pour qu'il
puisse voir la voiture quand elle est au
fond la course dure 30 minutes le pilote
réalisant le plus de tours ou gagne
comme en formule un à un les stands et
les mécaniciens permettent de
ravitailler les véhicules en essence
avec des réglages stratégique
particulier comme alexis clément
vainqueur de cette manche on a beaucoup
travaillé sur les pneus une fois qu'on
avait trouvé notre base de
réglage de voitures scène voilà mes
difficultés de cette puce dirait
et la longueur les deux virages au fond
là-bas sont loin et pour ceux qui n'ont
pas forcément rouler dessus ouais je
dirais ça la première difficulté le mord
pas yann brys grosjean a connu des
difficultés de moteur il repêché dans
une course particulière le premier est
qualifié en finale
après quelques minutes brice réussi à
prendre la tête
[Musique]
s'ensuit une bagarre entre les bolides
miniatures avec une victoire finale de
brice et à le commentateur de la course
qui qui commande donc c'est déjà ça
donne un stress plus après le stress de
la course
réussir à garder sa place de premier
après move pas une nouvelle manche du
championnat de france se déroulera à
castres du 12 au 14 octobre 2018 rugby
ce samedi le club de montigny le
bretonneux a inauguré son nouveau pôle
sportif au stade roger couderc un projet
dans les cartons depuis le début des
années 2000 aujourd'hui deux terrain
synthétique flambant neuf dont un
homologué pour les compétitions sont à
désormais accessible et coût total de
l'opération 1,3 million d'euros
les réactions au micro de nicolas landry
ça va permettre de s'entraîner
correctement tout l'hiver
à titre d'exemple cette saison terrain
en herbe est restée fermée en moi
et à montigny il n'y a pas de gymnase de
pas de gymnase disponibles donc on est
resté un mois à s'entraîner ça va
permettre de jouer de jouer des matchs
sur les terrains synthétiques l'hiver je
pense que l'entraînement les joueurs
reviendront plus volontiers en sachant
qu'ils vont pas finir avec cinq
centimètres de boue sur le corps créé
des terrains synthétiques aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose qui coûte
effectivement beaucoup d'argent mais il
faut quand même savoir que sur montigny
on a onze mille onze mille sportifs gît
par 11 mille le rugbyman mais en mille
sportifs
donc on se doit aussi de leur donner des
installations qui surveillent leur
permettent de pratiquer et ses terrains
à porteront le nom de pierre paillasse
ange ancienne adjointe au maire déléguée
aux sports décédé l'année dernière il
avait également été président de la smb
rugby pendant 13 ans
chaque année à la fin à la fin juin
c'est la journée internationale du yoga
une date
instituée par les nations unies en 2014
la ville de montigny le bretonneux à
marquer le coup ce dimanche avec un
événement découverte les visiteurs ont
pu tester l activité petite séance avec
nicolas landry et tous qui n'irait lanto
rendre le yoga plus visible c'est
l'objectif à montigny le bretonneux le
24 juin
c'était journée découverte au centre
pierre de coubertin deux associations de
yoga ont accueilli les adeptes d'un jour
90 personnes pour s'initier gratuitement
à l'activité
c'est la deuxième journée que l'on sent
que nous organisons à montigny
depuis l'année dernière c'est un moyen
de faire connaître de yoga à un pur en
population une deuxième journée
internationale du yoga montini sous
l'égide de l'ambassade indienne l'inde
est le pays d'origine du yoga il y
occupe toujours une place très
importante et nous en inde c'est un mode
de vie un mode de vie j'entends une
pratique complète qui s'insère dans
notre façon de vivre
quand nous sommes à bout fatigue est
incapable d'être attentif nous
concentrons sur le souffle nous faisons
du yoga c'est notre moyen pour être
tranquille une planète détente
musculaire meilleure gestion des
émotions le yoga semble séduire en
france mais ne fait pas du yoga qui veut
patience régularité encadrement sont
nécessaires pour cette activité
si le yoga procurent des bienfaits il
reste d'abord pour exigeant en fait
le yoga est bon pour le dos maintenant
quand il ya des blessures quand il ya
des hernies discales des douleurs
chroniques demandes de toute façon pour
la pratique toujours un certificat
médical c'est important et puis après
ben c'est aussi au port aux personnes de
respecter leurs limites c'est à dire que
le yoga s'adapte à la personne et non l
inverse
vu le succès rencontré cette année les
organisateurs pourraient de nouveau
organisé une journée de ce type l'an
prochain la fête de la musique a joué
les prolongations ce week-end notamment
à guyancourt où des concerts était
programmée samedi soir à la batterie
retour avec mélanie poquet et nicolas
landry
[Musique]
un début tout en douceur avec l'école de
musique à guyancourt la fête de la
musique a mis en avant les talents
locaux comme ses élèves clarinettistes
il ya toutes les formations jeu cros
quasiment tout ce produit c'est vraiment
le peut-être le moment phare de l'année
passée un choix en même temps on a le
droit de faire que du critique de jazz
mais ouais on aime bien toucher un petit
peu
à tous les sites à tous les styles
répartiront où c'est de la bonne musique
à la batterie on a vu les choses en
grand
cinq scènes et 40 groupes et artistes
tous les styles tous les âges et même
des renaissance
les rockeurs de sans limites se sont
reformés pour l'occasion c'est pour
permettre sans limite d'âge
aa je vais te dire un peu de moi j'ai 66
bas on a tous 60 ans qua non pour lui
pour qu'on est potes depuis koné connais
tu lis ces gaz il en a pas moins que du
monde plus que des groupes qui se
dessine à la professionnalisation comme
les jam walker qui ont gagné le tremplin
de la batterie l'année dernière et puis
d'autres effectivement qu'ils sont là
juste pour le plaisir qui répète une
fois par semaine comme d'autres vont à
la piscine au fond du macramé
du tricot chaque année ce rendez-vous
attire près de 4000 les nomades et puis
un avant goût de vacances à trappes avec
la fête de la ville qui se tenait ce
week-end une journée familiale qui
donnait le top départ de la belle saison
camille lambert nicolas landry de quoi
donner le tournis
cette pieuvre c'est l'attraction phare
cette année de la fête de la ville de
trappes
les habitants de la commune mais aussi
les voisins se sont déplacés exprès pour
l'occasion
cette famille de maurepas vient chaque
année au départ ça va très bien quand ça
bouge pas mais alors quand ça tourne ça
commence à vraiment à faire des bonnes
sensations surtout qu'en plus ça dure et
un petit peu l'otan pour moi la début ça
tourne ça tourne vers vers un parterre
et après ça me dirait que ça va taper
dans ma tête quand on tourne
manèges animations jeux mais aussi
activités sportives pendant que certains
se prenaient pour les joueurs du mondial
d'autres jouets les ouistitis bachelet
d'affaires un peu d'escaladé la
motricité surtout parce qu'il a du mal
avec la motricité donc ça l'aide au delà
de l'amusement cette fête avait aussi
une portée éducative
les visiteurs ont pu découvrir les
animaux dans la ferme pédagogique
on a fait un petit quizz un petit jeu
des 7 différences entre les différentes
espèces animales présentes et entre la
chèvre le mouton le coq et la poule et
puis aussi entre lan et le poney et puis
bien évidemment parler de l'animal du
respect animal comme en avant goût de
vacances avec le retour de l'été
autre rendez vous incontournable de la
ville tra plage qui revient du 9 juillet
jusqu'au 14 août
c'est la fin de ce journal très bonne
soirée et excellente semaine sur tv 78
[Musique]